okay John damn I've only got three dogs
after that says house you're the manager
use the perrito principle in his favor
at work I find myself constantly
focusing on the bottom five 20% that
causes eighty ninety five percent of the
team's poor performance
oh that's easy the managerial literature
the solid managerial literature is
absolutely crystal clear on this spend
all your time with your highest
producers and put your lowest producers
where they can do the least amount of
damage the probability that as a manager
you're going to be able to solve the
problems of the poorest five to 20
percent of your work team is zero you
just don't have the time or the
resources at your disposal so what you
should Jed definitely do in order to
increase performance is to concentrate
on your top performers I know that's not
what managers do they do exactly what
you say they focus on the bottom five to
twenty percent but that's exactly the
wrong thing to do as a manager focus on
your best people they're hyper
productive as you already know so you
know maybe you need to reconsider a key
with your people but you should have
regular conversations at least with
those that you think are outstanding let
them know that you really what would you
say that you're really happy with their
performance and see what you can do to
get obstacles the hell out of their way
because as a manager essentially what
you should be doing is identifying the
top performers and then doing everything
you can to clear out obstacles in their
path that's the right way to think about
it and also to give yourself enough time
to develop a medium to long term plan
and start fighting fires on a day to day
basis you need at least 90 minutes a
week to think about where you want
things to be going in the medium to long
term so but I can't add overemphasize
the importance of dealing with your talk
productivity your talk your highest your
most productive people that's where all
the games are that's where all the games
are